nicolas rey bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
chroniqueur avec franz olivier giesbert
sur france 3 et avec stéphane bern sur
france inter oui et vous venez d'avoir
un bébé transition ce qui aurait été
possible mais non pas vous promener le
dimanche après-midi en poussant la
poussette au bord du canal saint-martin
pas au bord du canal saint martin aime
et vous colle un coup oui voilà et
lorsqu est terrible c'est que al'inverse
quand je voyais que je n'étais pas papa
ouais le dimanche ou le samedi
des gens comme ça avec des milliards de
poussettes parce que c'est ce qui est
devenu paris un peu je crois qu'il a
encore faim ou pas pareil pour manger
voilà le manger aussi matinée un petit
peu fort mais manger mais quand même
tartus n osa je vous envie de manger des
halles et le boucher n'ont attaqué salée
aujourd'hui elle exhale une tontine
cardiaque plus nombreux dormir dormir
voilà me mets moi alors que j'étais je
tempère modèle qui pousse le landau rue
caulaincourt mais en même temps vous
faites les déclarations extraordinaire
vous avez dit la sodomie et la sexualité
du refus le besoin immanent de pervertir
les attitudes [ __ ] une fille c'est
refuser le quotidien
[Rires]
c'est à ses goûts mais en plus vous avez
raison c'est assez beau très honnêtement
c'est un très bon pour réfléchir à ces
[Rires]
bruits c'est un refus du quotidien vous
avez raison c'est un refus de l'habitude
pourquoi un argent oui oui ça peut être
ça aussi
nicolas en cours et celles un peu les
lumières lie tous peut-être des choses
on n'a pas ce que je m'occupe un peu de
la question dans mon livre c'est pour ça
que ça va encore être son tour nicolas
oui comment ça va le quotidien en ce
moment ça va le quotidien ça va très
bien dont je pense que certains plaisirs
où certaines comme sa beauté où certains
moments d'intensité extrême qui
s'arrache au passé au présent et la
chute prévisible sont possibles
uniquement avec un peu de douleur ou
difficultés et ces voix là et donc ça me
faisait penser un peu à la sodomie
nicolas rey bonsoir vous publié chez
grasset votre très attendu cinquième
roman qui s'appelle vallauris plage
alors le pitch et comment devenir un
assassin par amour le temps d'un été
c'est l'histoire de france trentenaire
mélancolique désabusé incarcéré pour une
peine de 15 ans qui se confie à sa jeune
avocate
il lui dit tout de la passion tragique
qu'il a eue pour celle qui l'a conduit
là une dénommée ariane bancaire voilà
alors ariane c'est la femme fatale
oui une fusée aussi
c'est aussi vénéneuse qui innocentent
collectionneuse donne énormément qu'un
seul mais enfin je pense que et là me
comprends tout à fait on peut à la fois
collectionner les mamans les caves
inondées mais qu'un sale c'est pas du
tout contradictoire
je vous comprends mais plus dans mes 30
ans maquette ahmad que d'accord pourquoi
parce que je pense que l'amour est un
sentiment qui est aussi déconnecté
parfois du besoin sexuel donc voilà si
on aime quelqu'un beaucoup très fort et
ça dépasse un moment donné le besoin
sexuel donc pu nicholas une sorte de
gérard philipe un peu je trouve comme ça
séducteur intelligent talentueux alors
déjà renoncé non ne pas y arriver alors
comment fait je vous relance ou trop
longs mois on se lance que martial à
vallauris plage donc c'est l'histoire de
n'était l'été où le drame se noue le
dernier arrêté voilà c'est ça c'est un
la première page du livre on découvre
que le narrateur a pris 15 ans femmes et
il va pendant tout le livre expliquer
pourquoi et le secret parce qu'il ya une
sorte de garde rapprochée comme ça qui
se retrouvent au bas loris plage qui
nous cache qui existe vraiment sur la
côte d'azur et il ya un secret c'est
ariane baker et il y a voilà comment ce
type arrivent à l'abject le temps d'un
le temps d'un livre et d'un polar il
sort d'un mais de temps en temps il
prend des douches mais danser danser
il pense alors ils pensaient ils pensent
à plein de choses
la pologne et c'est qui cet ami qui vous
accompagnent la cleda depuis tout à
l'heure en ça fait quand même trois
heures 15 quelle galère qu'elle attend
je m'en doutais bien pas
[Applaudissements]
non
regardez ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
les séries il ya de la meuf do you speak
only in english
ok on est en train de faire la promotion
du fils de nicolas on n'y arrive pas
donc je te propose un voyage formidable
right to take the promotion of my book
le tice de riz difficult nicolas la
noyade mais nicolas ly moi la page 61 à
partir de lecoufle falacci n'a pas fait
l'amour depuis dix mois le couple phil
et china pas fait l'amour depuis huit
mois
le dernier coït a duré six minutes un
accouplement essentiel cela faisait très
longtemps qu'il n'avait rien en fait il
fallait bien s'y remettre il faut bien
que les corps se force un peu ainsi va
la grande histoire d'amour
l'union qui rassure l'acte qui perpétue
une illusion à défaut de l'espèce il
faut du courage pour perpétuer
l'illusion parfois il faut du courage
pour tous c'est bien le problème du
courage pour se dévêtir il faut être une
véritable héroïne du couple pour se
coucher autrement que d'ordinaire on est
si bien d'ordinaire dans son pantalon de
soie avec un livre dans un chandail
tranquille dans une chemise de nuit
personne pourtant nuillé et voilà que
tout recommence
il faut tout ouvrir un peu les cuisses
et y placer une queue à moitié dur est
morte de trouille il faut éteindre la
lumière
il ne faut plus redoutés l'autre avoir
peur vu du ciel cela donne quoi
et le soulagement coupable d'après on a
baisé tout va bien tranquille pour
quelques temps ensuite être seul mais
savoir que l'autre est là et le manque
insupportable lorsqu'il s'en va trop
longtemps et tout qui recommence le mois
d'après et je pourrais continuer des
heures comme ça franchement je trouve ça
pas trop mal
y a bien pu pousser par lula depuis j'ai
entendu ça là j'étais dans la loge pour
[Rires]
messaoud vécu ensemble mais on n'a
jamais vécu ensemble
mais si quand il avait son cerveau et à
ramasser tout ça ça vous lui vit
ensemble vous étiez ensemble parce que
finalement on apprend qu ariane est une
nymphe aux premières pages 101 nicolas
bachand ainsi tu veux d'accord au bar
boisé du negresco notre homme aperçoit
cette fille à quelques mètres le regard
noyé dans sa coupe de champagne
incroyable cette fille il aperçoit à son
tour et lui sourit un beau sourire
triste et grave
bien sûr dans quelques temps il va se
jeter contre le mur d'une ferme sur une
route départementale bien sûr ce ne sera
qu'un accident auparavant dans les
toilettes du negresco ariane leur a pris
dans sa bouche brûlante puis elle se
serait retourné elle aura soulevé sa
jupe mauvais ample en le regardant
puis elle se sera penché comme aucun
être humain est capable de se pencher
ariane offre toujours son cul avec un
don inouï d'animalité et de délicatesse
on a même mouvement cambrai les fesses
nues il est difficile de faire un choix
entre ariane et la naïveté
doit-on vraiment plaindre ce monsieur de
48 ans doit-on regretter qu'il laisse
bientôt son poste à quelqu'un d'autre
ce poste formidable de chef produit dans
les amandes douces
voilà
donc voilà donc je te perds en anglais
c'est énorme
moi j'adore parce qu'il arrive un ne
l'engageait du langage vulgaire avec la
poésie et voilà c'est très bon et
coutumes s'il est ce qu'on peut dire de
mieux contrôler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le risque
c'était la fête
[Musique]